>>GOTIAT
HOLLYWD THWRITERS GUILD AREXDINO
RAPHAEL
WRITERS,OININGAL OTHERNOUODUCTI
WS THAHANG
ODNTACIN, TTER PAY ANDA CHANGE D
AW
THE ACTORSLD
TWNTR MANY OF
S, THEY ALSO
WANTTHAT PROTECTRS AGAIN SOF ARI
I'M RITER AND
SHOWWHO.OD TO SEE YOU,.
MODAPS NIAN
T UNDER D THERE COULD BE
>> AS OFTRAINED NOT TO BE OPTIM
ABOUT YTHING.
OPP ALL THE
I HOPE WE CAN A MUCH BETTER
I WANT TO BE WORK. AGEOW
>>T E A LOT OF WRITERS GH
WH IMAKE IN THE ATORTING
1990AKE A LIVING
FULL-TIME AS A CWORKIN AN MONTHT
OF THE
NOE ON
THO YOU T BYMES YOU COULMERK HE
E MOTHEY'VE LOST TT OUK NINE
T
OB INTO IM
URSES, I HA BOOK OUT, WHATEVER
>> IT'BED FOT OF BECAUSSOE ARS
LE THAT.
>>M SUN.
I DON'T KN W
THE WRITERS, BUT A
I JUST SHOW UPEGREES
>>WHEN YERG JULY, WYOLE BIT HO
WHAT IT IS NE  ON
MORE WEIGHT AND POPAUSE.
>>N, YOU KNOW, ANED SOME SHO ARG
E AIXTK.
THEY M THE FAVR
THEY HANDWTIWN
DR B, HETOCTION, B TAKINA IN
TOINOM THEH SHGO
THEY WON'HA
EXPLAI GETTING HEA
I THINK EVERYONE HEAT.REW'S CASH
PEG, ENDEARING, SHE SEEMS V
EMPATHETIC.
D OF DIND.RE PRESSURWEN
THE STUDIOS TO M, TH
STS COMES TO
NGK ONTAT PRESSURE. IN TH.
WHEN YOUR KIWRONG, YOUJUNE
DON'T LOVTH YOU DIS
THOFE ED IN ARE NT
O GEBA
S WE EANNOT.HAT IN
IT AN T STRIKE  ON ONIN TERMS ?
THERIGKE IS  SHOFUTURE - IR GOAE
>> HAVING ON IT.>> THANK YOU SOU
>>BSH YOU.YBY NTS SO